bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 9 février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour autour sur votre actualité
locale entouré de nos invités mais
également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite les titres de ce
mardi 9 février qui représentera la
région au concours national du meilleur
apprenti boucher lundi six jeunes
apprentis franciliens se sont affrontés
à versailles nous avons suivi les
concurrents à travers les différentes
épreuves les violences faites aux femmes
un sujet en ce moment au coeur de
l'actualité avec le procès de jacques
sauvage
l'association des étudiants en droit de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines juriste
tribune a choisi de reconstituer le
procès d'une autre affaire similaire
presque celle de alexandra longe cette
femme a quitté en 2012 du meurtre de son
mari et comment réaliser un long métrage
sans argent c'est la question que s'est
posée yanis et guillard un jeune
réalisateur de 20 ans cet ancien
étudiant de l'école troisième à réaliser
un film avec ses propres moyens
aujourd'hui il souhaite le diffuser
auprès du grand public il sera en
plateau avec elle n'attend gaumont un de
ses acteurs pour nous en parler et cet
après midi élus et riverains de magny
les hameaux se sont rassemblés devant la
pmi protection maternelle et infantile
de la commune pour protester contre sa
fermeture décidée par le conseil
départemental c'est le maire parti
socialiste bertrand ou non qui a
organisé ce rassemblement
l'ancien maire de la commune jacques
beaulieu avait lui aussi fait le
déplacement vous le voyez à l'image il
tait nombreux à se mobiliser contre
cette fermeture qui pourrait avoir lieu
dès demain
bertrand ou lyon je le rappelle sera
l'invité du 7-8 politique pour revenir
sur ce sujet il évoquera également les
rapports entre l'opposition et la
majorité de 50 en yvelines et les
tensions qui perdurent
l'émission a retrouvé à partir de 21h
qui rend ce mercredi et l'artisanat mise
à l'honneur hier au cfa de versailles a
eu lieu la présélection régional du
meilleur apprenti boucher de france un
titre convoité est remporté par un jeune
parisien
objectif de ce goncourt promouvoir le
métier de boucher et motiver les
apprentis car le secteur de la boucherie
ne connaît pas la crise
retour sur ce concours avec fanny
bourdillon devenir le meilleur apprenti
boucher de france c'était tout l'enjeu
pour ces six étudiants lors de la finale
régionale arrivé 4e ex-aequo james en
alternance aux halles de versailles a
manqué d'un peu de temps le temps le
tance t shirts trice ans après voilà
cent enfin au bout d'un an et demi c'est
pas on n'est pas forcément des bêtes de
concours quoi eh bien voilà on aurait
aimé se donner un peu plus qu'un agneau
veau boeuf et volaille
les apprentis ont eu une matinée pour
préparer quatre pièces de viande sous
l'oeil attentif du jury dans leurs
dotations c'est le désossage l'étape aux
plus forts coefficients des os et c'est
d'enlever les hausses 101 grammes de
viande ce volet faut laisser le père y
sommes attachés au moins aux muscles
voilà et après il faut regarder
l'horizon le désossage le parage le
parage s'est enlevé les impuretés le 22
grammes des nerfs qui sont non
consommables pour la clientèle après ces
étapes vient le ficelage puis la
décoration qui est très importante pour
la commercialisation de la viande bayou
entre le producteur et le cuisinier le
métier de boucher connaît ces dernières
années un regain d'intérêt contrairement
à ce qu'on pense n'est pas un métier
salle negore donc c'est un métier
vraiment où il ya l'art de transformer
la viande travail et une belle viande
reste toujours un vrai plaisir parce
qu'il a une dimension artistique
si ce qu'on on met pas souvent en
évidence mais c'est vraiment très
important de savoir vraiment transformer
la viande la mettre en valeur
conseiller la clientèle et voilà pouvoir
rapporter sa vraie valeur ajoutée
1er prix régional garant cela dit
garance candidats parisiens ont remporté
la première place
il accède ainsi à la finale nationale
les 10 12 avril prochain à strasbourg
urbanisme à présent l'immeuble
international de saint quentin en
yvelines construit en 1976 est devenu
obsolète aujourd'hui vide à 80%
l'agglomération a décidé d'offrir à cet
immeuble une profonde restructuration le
chantier devrait démarrer à l'été 2000
est avec la construction de nouveaux
bureaux mais également de nouveaux
logements les détails avec sephora
namani et patrick jacques de dixmude
édifié en 1976 à côté de la gare et
l'immeuble international est le premier
immeuble de bureaux construits à saint
quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui obsolète évident à 80%
saint-quentin-en-yvelines propriétaire
du terrain s'associe à un promoteur pour
permettre le financement du nouveau
chantier du quartier du centre nous en
tant que collectivité en tant
qu'aménageur on a mis un cahier des
charges dessus qui indiquent très
clairement à l'opérateur ce qu'il doit
faire en terme de qualité architecturale
mais aussi en terme de programmation
le projet de restructuration prévoit la
réalisation d'une zone d'activité de 19
mille trois cents mètres carrés de
bureaux des espaces de coworking 490
places de stationnement un restaurant et
une crèche d'entreprise également la
création de 132 logements dont 89 en
accession à la propriété et 43 logements
sociaux cette mixité elle est là deux
intérêt je voulais dire premier intérêt
financier évident et le deuxième c'est
aussi on est proche
une proche de la gare donc il ya toute
utilité à mettre des logements ici parce
que parce que les gens besoin de cette
proximité avec des transports en commun
montant global de l'opération 90
millions d'euros
le dépôt du permis de construire est
prévu pour la fin mars la
commercialisation des bureaux pour le
deuxième trimestre de l'année
début des travaux prévu en 2017 pour une
livraison de la nouvelle structure en
2019 et cap à présent sur voisins le
bretonneux les travaux de réaménagement
de la place et des douches situées à
proximité de la mairie ont démarré du
béton va être déposée sur l'ensemble de
la place pour remplacer le gravier
stabiliser les douves vont être
également nettoyé et les luminaires
passeront oled des espaces verts seront
également installés la maire de la
commune alexandra rosetti était au micro
de michael et demi d'euros et nous en
dit plus on a choisi de refaire cette
place pour la rendre beaucoup plus
agréable draps plus cet aspect gras
millionnaire qui faisait que pour finir
en bas les chiens
venez faire leurs besoins et qui rendait
cette place peu accueillante
le mobilier urbain va être va être
changé et on a voulu garder quand même
l'esprit village de voisins à cet
endroit il y aura également quelques
places de stationnement supplémentaires
qui vont être créés voilà donc simple et
un projet d'ensemble où je dirais pour
le petit t-il eu un peu commerçants qui
alla et les établissements secondaires
post-baccalauréat continue d'ouvrir
leurs portes pour informer et faire
découvrir leur formation aux futurs
bacheliers
ce week-end c'était au tour de l'école
nationale supérieure d'architecturé de
versailles qui fêtait d'ailleurs c'est
disons d'ouvrir ses portes en france
elle est l'une des 20 écoles publiques
qui dispense en son enseignement
supérieur de la chaire de l'architecturé
des livres en cinq ans le diplôme d'état
d'architecte
l'établissement accueille 140 étudiants
chaque année sur concours
les précisions au micro de camille
lambert effectivement assez sélectif
mais c'est aussi une façon de préserver
au sein de l'école une qualité pour la
pédagogie un terrain pour
d'apprentissage remarquable de façon à
ce que chaque étudiant soit bien encadré
et dispose d' espace au sein de l'école
on a évidemment un observatoire des
débouchés cet observatoire des débouchés
montre que lors de la première année
après le diplôme 90 % des étudiants sont
en général salariés ou en tout cas sous
en activité deux cent mille femmes à
part en seraient victimes de violences
conjugales mais seulement 10% déposerait
plainte 134 femmes sont mortes sous les
coups de leur conjoint conjoint violent
pardon juste sur l'année 2014 en france
des chiffres et au delà des situations
dramatiques qui sont revenus sur le
devant de l'actualité ces dernières
semaines nous en parlons à présent ce
soir avec et wilfrid richy pour ça
bonsoir florane tout simplement nous
parlons de ce sujet car le président de
la république a décidé d'accorder une
remise gracieuse de sa peine
d'emprisonnement à jacqueline sauvage
pourtant condamné à dix ans de prison
pour le meurtre de son mari violent
c'est donc un véritable problème de
société qui a été soulevée avec les
limites de la justice puisqu'il a fallu
qu'un président intervienne nous en
avons d'ailleurs parlé sur ce plateau la
semaine dernière dans le journal
vendredi dernier avec chantal paoli
texier c'est la présidente de
l'association agissez contre la violence
et le
le moral une association basée sur mort
pas écouté cet extrait ce procès c'est
aussi le désaveu enfin le désaveu cesser
la mise en abyme du fait que la justice
ne comprennent pas la notion d'emprise
et que 47 ans d'emprise ça ça marque une
femme sa marque toute une famille on
sait que sa fille ont été victimes voilà
c'est fini
son fils est le fils est d'ailleurs
suicide est juste avant que sa mère
n'assassine son père donc il ya des
corrélations qui aurait dû être fait
qu'ils n'ont peut-être pas été fait
je pense que au delà de 2 ce qui s'est
passé pour jacqueline sauvage c'est
effectivement toute la question de la
notion d'emprise et de sa méconnaissance
par la justice que ce procès interpelle
les réactions politiques concernant la
faire à jacqueline sauvages ont
également été nombreuses seulement on
comprend pour bien faire évoluer les
choses il faut revenir à la base et la
base bien sûr elle se trouve dans les
universités les écoles de droit le droit
qui doit évoluer pour la france cela
signifie peut-être de s'inspirer ce qui
est de ceux qui existent à l'étranger le
canada par exemple ce pays reconnaît la
présomption de légitime défense pour les
femmes victimes de violence et l'emprise
qu'elles subissent en attendant elle les
jeunes générations ont saisi
l'importance de ce sujet en témoigne le
projet de l'association juriste tribune
chaque année cette association portée
par des étudiants de saint quentin en
yvelines reconstituant un grand procès
de l'histoire la sphère dominici en 2013
l' affaire à nous toucher ensuite cet
homme on se souvient condamné à la peine
de mort par guillotine en 1976 pour le
meurtre d'une fillette ces
reconstitutions permettent donc de
soulever des questions de société
d'évolution de la société et le 4 mars
l'association va se pencher sur le
dossier d'alexandra lange
alexandra longe cette femme a quitté en
2012 du meurtre de son mari
les axes exactement l inverse pardon de
jacqueline sauvage alexandra lange a été
acquitté pour la reconstitution ce sont
les étudiants qui vont jouer le rôle d
accuser des juges des avocats des
professionnels vont les aider avocats
enseignants tout cela se fait dans une
grande précision écouter l'étudiante en
charge du projet cette année c'est très
très long il ya du travail préparatoire
parce qu'il faut chercher énormément de
documents il faut chercher des sources
fiables parce que ben on a beau dire
internet c'est pas très très fiable
alors on est désertique mais des prises
à partie
on a la chance sur ce procès d'avoir
d'avoir des télés qui ont pu filmer tout
le procès dont on a pu voir les images
on a eu la chance d'avoir certains
acteurs réels du procès qui ont pu nous
apporter une aide et des précisions que
nous n'avions pas on a aussi la chance
d'avoir eu le livre a quitté qui avait
paru part à l'édition michel lafon qui a
été écrite par alexandre allonger ses
avocates
pour vous donner plus de détails sur ce
dossier pendant douze ans le mari
d'alexandra à l'ange là-bas telles
insultes l humilier le soir du 18 juin
2009 son mari venait de battre leur
fille de 10 ans juste avant de tenter de
l'étrangler elle se défend et lui plante
un coup de couteau nous sommes dans le
cadre d'une affaire dont coût en terme
de code pénal s'appliquerait
parfaitement l'article 221-1 donc sur
les homicides volontaires
la culpabilité est avérée malgré tout le
procureur pour une position absolument
inédite en ne faisant pas une
application du droit tel qu'il aurait dû
la faire c'est ça qui est intéressant
dans cette affaire c'est que on sort
dans ce procès d'un cadre uniquement
légal on sort d'un cadre procédural
classique et d'une application classique
du code pénal et pour un jury c'est
forcément très intéressant parce qu'on
est au bord de ce qu'on peut faire
alors on parle de reconstitution mais ce
n'est pas pour autant uniquement un jeu
de rôle dont car les étudiants vont
devoir juger et la libre à eux de
réécrire l'histoire coupable aux
acquittés forcément le contexte les
affaires de ces derniers mois vont jouer
dans la décision sur le plan historique
en tout cas on remarquera qu'en 2012
alexandra lange avait été acquitté alors
qu'en 2016 il a fallu l'intervention du
président pour la faire jacqueline
sauvage la justice qui a donc du mal à
évoluer sur cette problématique a avancé
reconstitution le 11 mars et non le 4 il
ya eu un report ce sera le 11 mars au
tribunal de grande instance de
versailles s'est ouvert au public qui
devrait donc être nombreux et puis juste
une dernière chose pour montrer combien
le sujet des violences conjugales des
violences faites aux femmes
intéressant en tout cas elle et futurs
avocats et pas uniquement depuis mars
2015 l'université paris 8 en partenariat
avec le département de seine saint denis
propose un diplôme de politiques de
prévention et de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
merci à vous les prix sans transition à
prendre un mot de culture la disparition
d'assia djebar l'une des auteurs les
plus influentes du maghreb a laissé le
faut
numéro 5 de l'académie française vacant
de candidats pour cette chaire frédéric
mitterrand ancien ministre de la culture
et arnould aaron gwin ch'ti linguiste
d'original versaillaise sephora namani
et fanny bourdillon vous rencontrer pour
nous regarder mathématicien et ingénieur
épistémologue et linguiste arnould
prince qui dénonce une rupture entre le
protecteur de l'académie française le
président de la république et
l'institution fondée en 16 134 en charge
de normaliser perfectionner la langue
française une rupture particulièrement
préjudiciable selon lui en période de
crise d'identité sociale
le 5 décembre 2013 l'académie a fait un
appel aux prix dans la public en tant
que protecteur héritiers louis xiv pour
lui demander de faire de 2014 l'année
l'année de reconquête de l'allant pas de
réponse le 21 janvier 2015 et dernier à
la suite des attentats
tout à coup on s'aperçoit qu'à langue
française et larmes numéro un anti
terroriste à ce qu'elle va permettre une
certaine gêne est de comprendre les
valeurs de la république
mais au lieu que ce soit suivi d'effets
et bien réforme des collèges le 11 juin
elle a fait un communiqué disant que
c'était encore un mauvais coup porté à
la langue
arnaud upinsky pour défendre la langue
française et réveiller les consciences
d'après lui se propose comme candidat au
fauteuil numéro 5 de l'académie
française laissé vacant par assia djebar
son talent de richelieu dit il est un
talent de mise en ordre de bataille
j'ai travaillé sur toutes les phases de
l'information chiffres lettres arts
sémantique et sémantique est donc sûre
sur la grammaire je suis la glisse il
n'y a pas beaucoup de linguistes si je
me dire un cas d'amy et surtout sur ma
combativité
c'est à dire que je fais du
positionnement stratégique
je travaille constamment sur la
construction d'une digue message et sur
la guerre sémantique dire sur le
truquage du langage et c'est ce dont
l'académie a besoin actuellement
c'est la première fois qu'un prétendant
à l'académie publie sa lettre de
candidature
une mesure nécessaire selon arnaud
upinsky qui explique qu'il est important
que français et académies puisse
comprendre les motivations et programmes
de chaque candidat l'élection fauteuil
numéro 5 est fixée au jeudi 3 mars
et nous parlons cinéma à présent comment
faire un long métrage sans moyens une
question à laquelle ont tenté de
répondre nous invité ce soir en plateau
avec moi yanis guillard bonsoir et
nathan govou sera vous de alors votre
premier long métrage king automatic va
être diffusé à l'école troisième ce
jeudi 11 février à 18 heures don kelly
garrett le réalisateur vous avez 20 ans
vous êtes yvelinois nathan com où vous
êtes acteur vous avez également réalisé
une partie de la bande originale vous
avez vingt deux ans vous êtes également
yvelinois on va parler justement de ce
projet de long métrage dont quelques
instants juste après regardez cette
bande annonce
alors voilà c'était un court extrait le
film donc je dure 1h15 à ce qu il ya
nice voulait nous faire un petit pitch
du film ah ouais bien sûr
alors là le film en fait on se base sur
l'histoire de flint
donc c'est un jeune délinquant qui a
perdu ses parents quand il était petit
et qui a pas réussi à avancer à partir
de là il a pas réussi à lancer dans la
vie est très rapidement un peu par
hasard il va entrer dans dans le gang de
deux gangsters un peu barré qui
s'appelle dino et mario et il va prendre
prendre il va prendre part à l'aventuré
tout simplement
et au fur et à mesure comme ça en
prenant part à leurs magouilles il va
essayer de se replonger sur son passé et
essayer de découvrir qui a fait ça à ses
parents et voilà et de mettre au clair
toute cette histoire vous vous classez
arias peut-être votre fils dans un genre
précis ou pas forcément alors non
justement c'est un film qui j'allais
vraiment décomposée en deux parties au
niveau du traitement il ya toute une
première partie qui est un peu plus
décalé un peu plus parodique avec des
influences un petit peu à la tarantino
et toute une autre partie vachement plus
sérieuse peu plus psychologique presque
psychédélique avec cette fois plus d
influence à la fincher donc de style un
peu différent mais dans le même film
alors on attend vous vous jouez quel
rôle justement dans cette fête ensuite
mais quand vous avez eu envie voilà de
participer à ce projet alors bas tout
d'abord c'est en fin de terminale
donc du coup la classe de terminer c'est
de ce projet donc remonte à trois ans
c'est ça exactement donc
donc je connais et yanis depuis depuis
quelques années maintenant et donc on
était dans une option cinéma au lycée et
donc on est parti là dessus en fait déjà
donc c'était vraiment une bande de
copains à la base on est partis
là-dessus on savait pas que ça allait
être un projet aussi long et donc que
moi à la base on ne conseille que ça
allait prendre deux mois et on a mis
plus de deux ans elle tournait bien
bientôt trois pour les diffuser que
votre rôle justement alors danser alors
donc moi je joue le rôle de flint donc
le personnage principal du film
donc voilà le personnage qui vivait un
petit peut se poser des questions sur
lui même tout au long du film et qui va
qui va vivre au jour le rôle au jour le
jour par don et qui va donc intégrer le
fameux gang un peu décalée de gino et
mario et qui va chercher sans cesse la
vérité notamment sur la mort de ses
parents parce qu en fait voilà le fait
que le personnage de film d'obtenir
temps se replonge sur son passé comme il
l'a dit c'est une vraie introspection en
fait il va se remettre en question et
est bon ça il le sait mieux que moi mais
c'est vrai ça voilà qui est intéressant
dans ce personnage
habituellement on commence par un court
métrage original quand on sort des
caladois est un long métrage pourquoi
justement alors fait ce choix bah c'est
en fait c'est un vrai défi voilà c'est
avant d'être un film c'était surtout un
projet surtout un défi unique
automatique on avait envie de dire au
delà de s'amuser entre potes que c'était
possible qu' il n'y avait pas besoin
d'avoir des moyens pas besoin d'avoir
une équipe si on n'avait pas d' équipes
techniques
ces acteurs qui cadrait c'était eux qui
prenaient le sens où c'était moi quand
je jouais pas dedans et on a voulu dire
que tout ça c'était possible et que si
on était motivés puis si si on avait
envie de le faire quoi on pouvait le
faire parce que des courts métrages y en
a qui se font tous les jours je pense
qu'on en a qui sortent en france tous
les jours et qui vont à des tas de
festivals mais je pense pas que des
longs métrages amateurs comme ça il y en
a beaucoup et alors justement un peu du
financement participatif ya beaucoup de
plateformes de financement comme lui les
lots merci qui propose justement voilà
de se faire financer vous n'avez pas eu
non vie est justement de choisir ce
format là et peut-être de faire appel à
le bas alors à l'époque déjà on enfin on
était vraiment jeune femme l'est
toujours mais du coup je m'intéresse est
vraiment
tout ce à quoi j'avais un peu la tête
dans le guidon je voulais faire mon film
juste avec mes potes avec mon petit
caméscope et mon petit enregistreur que
je coachais sur un manche à balai
prendre leçon mon enregistreur celle ci
a d'ailleurs vu que les musiciens et on
se prenait vraiment pas la tête avec des
questions de matériel ni rien donc à
vrai dire j'ai même pas pensé comment
s'est lancé dans un terminal mais c'est
vrai qu'on aurait pu le faire c'est vrai
qu'on aurait pu avoir plus de moyens
même temps voilà ç'aurait été pas été
serait pas été le même film mais le
projet aurait été différente que je suis
content qu'on soit quand même passé par
là c'était pas de première expérience n
attend qu recteur ouais c'était
totalement donc première expérience j'ai
été séduit quand il ya nice m'a proposé
d'être le personnage principal et je
trouve que c'est une super expérience et
tout le monde peut se lancer là dedans
tout le monde qui s'intéresse un peu au
domaine artistique
je les encourage vraiment et vous avez
également réalisé donc là une grande
partie de la bande sonore là aussi vous
avez travaillé tout seuls dans votre
coin comme ça c'est un peu passé alors
donc du coup pour pour tout ce qui est
musique donc c'est yanis qui m'a un
petit peu coach est là dessus qui m'a
demandé qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient
c'était surtout des dd sont un petit peu
d'ambiance que moi j'ai essayé avec mon
style de musique
je laissais rock'n'roll voix la musique
assez assez porté sur le roc de coller à
un petit peu au registre du film un
petit peu voilà violent ratinaud un peu
rock'n'roll
donc pour faire tous ces sons d'ambiance
le moindre petit sont sûres sur un
changement de scène dont toi là parce
qu'il ya eu ça il ya aussi c'était plus
gros travail bien sûr mais il ya eu
quelques musiques aussi vraiment à part
entière qui ont été composées par nathan
voilà et c'est vrai que c'était des
musiques vraiment bien rock'n roll qui
collait au film un peu révolté quoi et
voilà j'ai gelé connu puisqu'il était
dans un groupe de musique et j'allais
pas mal de ses concerts donc c'est donc
aujourd'hui à vous l'assuré c'est
possible de faire un film de l'univers
500 d'argent mais comment on pense un
pro c'est ça la bonne question
c'est je pense qu'on peut tout faire
sans argent après le problème c'est le
temps c'est en a pris deux ans le faire
parce que c'est vrai que voilà c'est
tout des amateurs tous les acteurs c'est
juste mes potes en fait et même s'ils
ont la meilleure volonté du monde un
moment donné ils font tous quelque chose
à côté ils ont tous leurs études ils ont
tous leur passe-temps leurs obligations
et au début on arrivait à se réunir à
peu près tous les week-ends pour tourner
et puis au fur et à mesure vu qu'on a
évolué dans le monténégro vient de temps
pour tourner le film en tout ça voilà
donc on a mis deux ans total 1,2 en mai
deux ans de tournage vraiment de deux
ans de tournage dirait une fois tous les
deux trois week-ends quoi
dès qu'on pouvait en fait alors la
finalité pour ce long métrage ça va être
là c'est un grand projet pour commencer
donc par la carte du cinéma pour vous 2
à quels sont les objectifs alors badiane
le premier temps là on est surtout sur
la promotion du film ont essayé de le
projeter à droite à gauche et de le
montrer au maximum de gens pour avoir
leur retour parce que je pense que dans
les milieux artistiques
ça sert à rien de faire un projet si on
en croit pas aux autres parce que c'est
fait pour être vu mais ensuite c'est
vrai que bah moi en tant que réalisateur
j'ai déjà commencé à écrire un autre
long métrage que j'aimerais cette fois
produire avec un peu plus de moyens pour
le projeter au cinéma
c'est un projet qui s'appellera floréal
vous êtes vous êtes à la recherche
également de juste pas de producteur
pour peut-être pouvoir relancer ce film
ouais pourquoi pas pourquoi pas oui
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas pensé mais si
c'est un producteur voulait leur tournée
de notre manière d'une manière un peu
professionnel on pourrait en discuter
donc vous allez présenter aussi ailleurs
dans d'autres festivals
c'est un long métrage donc c'est plus
compliqué que les convaincre qu'ils sont
plus facilement diffusable dans des
festivals qui leur sont dédiés c'est ça
alors bon on va le dire on va essayer de
le faire participer à tout un tas de
festivals mais dans un domaine dans un
deuxième temps là pour pour le moment on
en rit et surtout des projections déjà
dans une semaine on va se projeter à
montpellier jeudi qu'il vient on va le
projeter à 3 y est donc à l encours et
voilà pensons surtout les projections
les festivals on verra après une écoute
on vous souhaite bonne chance je le
rappelle donc le long métrage de ping
automatique et diffusé jeudi 11 février
donc à l'école la troisième à 18 heures
voilà c'est ouvert à tout le monde
n'hésitez pas à venir le regarder si
vous voulez découvrir le travail de
yanis guillard n'hésitez pas non plus à
consulter son site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran merci
beaucoup monsieur d'avoir accepté notre
invitation au sida ont cédé à merci
c'est très gentil et tout de suite pour
refermer ce journal une page de sport
l'événement n'avait pas pu se dérouler
en novembre 2015 à cause des attentats
mais les organisateurs ont tenu quand
même à organiser la 14e rang de castor
la course d'orientation s'est tenue à
bois d'arcy ce week-end 566 personnes
s'étaient donné rendez vous dimanche
matin
c était quoi je regardais ce reportage
signé mais annie potier et patrick
jacques de dixmude dernière explication
pour les novices derniers préparatifs
avant le départ les participants se sont
rassemblés au stade jean-moulin de bois
d'arcy
c'est vraiment pour le plaisir d'être
dehors avec d'autres gens de découvrir
la course d'orientation
et mon objectif peut-être essayer de
terminer en 2h30 connaissaient leur
apprend la compétition mais là le
plaisir avant tout et de réchappe
récupère toutes les balises de finir de
se ressaisir et de s'amuser un temps
alors le corps vous la valise elle doit
aller toute voix pour 1 voix là et des
gars sur qui le deuxième film chemin qui
tient dans l'es3 avec cinq circuits de 8
à 18 km et un sixième pour les plus
jeunes la 14e édition a rassemblé 5 166
participants licenciés ou non
c'est vraiment une course pour la
promotion de la de la discipline puisque
on a à peu près 70 % de non licenciés à
la fédération de corse orientation donc
ce sont des gens vraiment qui viennent
découvrir ou pratiquer cette discipline
sans forcément être licenciés sur le 18
km pierrick pages le vainqueur a terminé
en 1h46
les orienteurs se donne déjà rendez vous
pour la prochaine aux castors en
novembre 2016 et c'est la fin de cette
édition je vous remercie nous avoir
suivis je vous donne rendez vous rendez
vous demain pardon pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée